[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I LOVE THAT MOVIE!
>> SO, ANYWAY -- THAT'S THE
LIST.
>> GOOD.
WHAT YOU GOT?
>> MY TALK OF THE TABLE A
MEDICAL STUDENT ACTUALLY WORKING
TO DIVERSIFY MEDICAL TEXTBOOKS
WITHAT ILLUSTRATIONS OF BRACK
PE
BLACK PEDI.
DIDN'T KNOW HOW MUCH I NEEDED
THIS UNTIL I SAW THK.
ILLUSTRATIONS.
A PREGNANT BLACK WOMAN.
BECAME A HIT.
FIRST MED STUDENT IN UKRAINE AND
HER ILLUSTRATIONS.
YOU DON'T REALIZE YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN IT UNTIL SOMEBODY SHOWS YOU
THIS.
BECAUSE TYPICALLY IS --
>> WOW.
>> A WHITE PERSON, AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT.
>> YES.
I HAVE NEVER, EVER SEEN THAT.
I LOVE HOW YOU SET IT UP.DN
DIDN'T REALIZE HOW MUCH I WAS
MISSING UNTIL I SAW IT.
>> YEAH.
>> NEVER SAW A PICTURE OF A
BLACK